kohn et comme 60% des français a déjà
fait l'amour en pensant à notre
partenaire à part benhaim on sait que
c'est à chaque fois non mais finalement
bien sûr vous avez pour ça que c'est
grâce aux gens vous ai jamais pensé à
moi
ah mais non désirées gérer c'est une
fois moussa cauchemar avait juré c'est à
lui d'y arriver de temps en temps je
m'excuse et moi je suis pas comme vous
faites des camps au fait vous faites ça
plusieurs fois que quelqu'un vous êtes
longtemps coupage du jarret c'est deux
mois quand vous êtes longtemps aussi
beau soit-il que vous avez couché 40 ou
50 fois que la même personne
il ya un moment tu vas lui mari
d'isabelle non à bagnolet j'ai le temps
de penser à quelqu'un personne ex femme
non non non il y en a tellement lui
céder dia
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'amour il pense alors à sa wii
mais c'est vrai que ça après tout
c'était déjà trouvé de prénom on peut
aussi bien sûr ça s'est trompé de près
droit rupture est arrivé alawi bin oui
alors vous êtes tranquille oui mais en
plus votre mari l'entend pas bien facile
pedro parce que je suis trop
[Rires]
fais-toi plaisir oui vous savez déjà
reliés mais c'est involontaire mais
c'est pas de ma faute c'est surtout à
cause d'une tendance ou bas qui dure
depuis déjà quelques années on peut le
dire le mot la levrette vous voyez ma la
tête de la personne et donc celle où
l'on se dit que ce qu'il va dire avait
longtemps cette fois eu la tête on ne va
pas revenir à chaque fois et du bon goût
il revient mais ces craintes alors est
ce que est ce que thibault vous vous
avez déjà fait l'amour en pensant à
notre partenaire aux noms n'ont jamais
allée des os et les dents mais à 60% des
français qui ont déjà fait l'amour en
penser un autre partenaire kelly non par
contre j'avais un index qui m'appelait
jessica de temps en temps non
fonctionnels hyper mal mais son ex sap
et jessica mais sa soeur aussi donc
certaines formules excusez moi dans ma
soeur s'appelle jessica c'est pire à ses
beats ap jessica aussi endormie me
faisait croire que non pas pendant robin
pour 10h au cbb naim ses deux frères
s'appelle igor et grichka
[Rires]
alors comme un français sur quatre c'est
à dire 25 % et 3 et geek comme un
français sur quatre est déjà tombé
amoureux sur son lieu de travail
ah bah oui avec flavie flament vous ça
vous est déjà arrivé thibault ah oui non
bah oui oui sur la vie des gosses là
c'est nouveau la non non c'est pas
nouveau c'est une histoire qui dure
depuis 14 ans fait elle a été mariée on
a été marié par par roger planchon qui
est un metteur en scène de théâtre
écrivain qui avait monté la dernière
pièce de d'aral painter qui s'appelait
célébration et ils nous avaient même en
mariée on se connaissait pas et voulait
rester ensemble et si vous êtes connu
quoi sur les réponses directes oui ban
hélas le coup de foudre mais ç'a pris du
temps aussi on s'était sur grue de
travail votre mac votre nouvelle femme
bah lui fait mal fait gaffe ça veut dire
que la prochaine femme alicia ça peut
tomber
je le connais ça peut tomber c'est vous
et votre chance
theron toi ce que tu as déjà trouvé
l'amour sur son lieu de travail une fois
je suis sur scène et je suis en train de
change suis maurice tôt si je suis en
train de faire des reflets légal ne pas
le savoir en tout cas et je suis dans le
public et je bloque sur elle et puis
j'oublie le texte et puis je commence à
lui parler ouais sur scène et je
l'épousé
ce soir personne d'autre non non non
nous sommes remontés que ça m'ennuie a
précisé c'est pas lésiné croire qu'après
je parle plus de ça non alors le corps
était au bureau s'était pas trouvé
l'amour
mais comme parfois on était stagiaire à
l'époque les stagiaires ont travaillé
beaucoup la journée bah du coup on était
cinq six stagiaires pour détendre le
soir parfois on faisait l'amour au
bureau mais oui mais j'étais stagiaire
c'était quoi la con quand on finit tard
voilà mais a pas d'amour non mais
attendez vous êtes fous des sports merci
de me comprendrez bien que ce que tout
le monde j'imagine élus sur cinq ans
alors que le rapport de stack j'ai vu
mathieu vous aviez pouffer 3 q
[Rires]
le maître de stage a mal à ça mais ça
m'a l'air d'être un bon cela dommage
moral